dass die deutsche psychologin und hätten
jetzt eine selbsthilfegruppe
was kannst du über jungs sagen was du
musst über ja
ok
ja ich glaub sympathisch ist der
kuschelt mit holz ist ein guter mann
hallo herzlich willkommen zum einem
neuen format per mai kitchen
[Musik]
ich habe die idee von pimp my ride
aufgegriffen und habe das ganze auch
sally umgemünzt das heißt ich werde
küchen aufpimpen aber ich habe mir dann
gedacht so bei der konzeptentwicklung es
soll nicht einfach nur darum gehen
küchen aufzupumpen sondern zum einen
küchen von ganz besonderen menschen
menschen die ihr schon kennt menschen
die ihr vielleicht nicht kennen und die
ich euch vorstellen werde aber es geht
eben auch darum euch mit auf die reise
zu nehmen eine küche zu planen zu
individualisieren auch was muss man
achten was ist ganz besonders wichtig
und vor allem gibt es auch eine richtig
große überraschung für euch denn am ende
gibt's auch noch eine community küche
das heißt ich werde jemand von euch
auswählen jemand der eine küche dringend
nötig hat einfach was neues brauch und
möchte euch mit einer neuen küche die
dann noch individualisiert wird
überraschen in diesem format werde ich
es auch so machen dass ich ganz bewusst
auch die marken nennen werde alles was
verbaut wird alles was ich zum
einrichten benutze der in mittlerweile
kenne ich euch ganz gut egal was ich
zeige es wird immer danach gefragt wo
hast du das her wo bekommt man es auch
was muss man achten deswegen gibt es
auch die pimp my kitchen de-seite da
könnt ihr doch alle infos nochmal
nachlesen im detail und hier in diesem
format werde ich euch einfach mit auf
die reise meinen ersten kandidaten das
erste versuchskaninchen das kennt ihr
sogar schon und zwar ist es ja schon
unser kameramann beim lorch weiß ich
dass er gerade eine neue wohnung gezählt
und da ist ja wirklich tag und
nachtragend und renovierte wohnung er
macht die decken selber die böden reißt
alles aus und macht wirklich komplett
alles neu und dann habe ich der josch
angesprochen und gefragt ob ich denn
nicht tipps und tricks habe zur
küchenplanung und ich habe mir gedacht
komm das wird jetzt die erste folge zu
meinem format und ich weiß sie ist
single als ledig erzählt jetzt das erste
mal von zu hause aus und es ist
praktisch eine wohnung die ihr zum
ersten mal beziehen wird ich habe ja mit
joschka war mit klaus in verbindung
gesetzt denn er hilft am joch auf der
baustelle und mit ihm habe ich das ganze
auch so ein bisschen organisiert damit
der ja eben auch nicht die ganze dabei
ist natürlich ist jetzt auch ganz
wichtig zu wissen was braucht in der j
überhaupt das heißt wenn auch ihr
zuhause eine küche planen wollt dann
geht am besten nicht planlos ins
küchenstudio das endet meistens kann ich
euch vorhersagen im streit denn meist
will der eine partner das eine der
andere das andere setzt sich am besten
hin und macht erstmal eine
bedarfsermittlung das heißt seit ihr
single oder ein pärchen habt ihr kinder
habt ihr haustiere all das sind
praktisch faktoren die in die küchen
planung mit einfließen sollten und
deswegen werde ich jetzt erstmal
herausfinden was der jung sprach ich
weiß ja so ein bisschen was über ihn er
ist sportlich er ist handwerklich begabt
er ist auch sehr kreativ was filmen
angeht aber natürlich weiß ich noch
nicht alles über josch und deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht frage ich doch mal
freunde von ihm und auch die kollegen
und kann dann noch mit euch gemeinsam
ein bisschen mehr über geworden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
holz ja und jetzt
also holz
immer wenig ein anrufer hatte irgendwas
am schreien und macht holzbretter glaubt
wenn man da ein paar details mit holz
vermischt und seiner küche wer das
glaubt schon ziemlich cool den gibt es
nur in kombination mit seinem roten
werden und wir sind eigentlich im sommer
und im winter zusammen sind surfen oder
snowboarden und da sind wenn wir dann
das land die küste unterwegs oder
irgendwo in den alpen und das macht uns
eigentlich ziemlich viel spaß irgendwie
kann es sein dass er vielleicht das
leben lebt was ich gern leben würde ich
weiß ich manchmal so vor
[Musik]
ich kenne keinen menschen der mehr musik
wird als jung ist halt einfach eine
große leidenschaft auch von ihm bin ich
runter geht und irgendwann schneidet
läuft immer irgendwo musik und er mag
diese so technische spielereien das
merkt auch eine kamera deshalb kann man
da irgendwas einbauen dass es bei dem
die ganze musik läuft
wir haben so ein solches und spitzname
für ihn also der mann weil er macht es
halt immer wasser macht macht er zu 100
prozent also in unserem büro bin ich die
ordentliche
die erste frage die jungs mir gestellt
hat als ich hier angefangen habe war ob
ich gerne etikettierer der jungs so
unordentlich ich reg mich jedes mal auf
und daraufhin habe ich erst mal so ein
bisschen verdutzt geschaut und sagt
irgendwas hey guck mal solche tieren und
dann wirklich jeder ist einfach wenn du
was perfekt gemacht hat dann sagte gut
diese deutsche sagt immer dann immer
bei allem was du bugs oder koch fragt ja
erstmal ob man es auch noch frittieren
könnt
weil seine eltern daheim habe ich mal so
eine kleine träger maschine geholt wo
auch so ein bisschen an des magister
game reingekommen ist er versuche ich
auch ein bisschen an latte art
so schwebe und
so
dass ich das so eine pflanze braucht man
heute aber kann das mittlerweile er
kriegt meisten die so ganz hin schick
mir dann bild von irgendwem weißen klos
war sagt guck mal das sieht aus wie ein
schwan aber
ich glaube ja auf jeden fall ein guter
kaffee trinker
ja so wie ich ihn nicht kennen ist
glaube ich ein estrich gar nicht so
wichtig sind dass er so gemütlich in der
runde in seiner küche steht vielleicht
in bar tresen oder so man ein zwei
entspannte bier oder einen trinken kann
das ist glaub nicht sein ding durch ihre
arbeit als kameramann hat er natürlich
auch sehr viel mit licht zu tun und ich
glaube wird schon sehr schätzen wenn man
ihm auch mit licht irgendwie die kirche
verschönert und indirekter beleuchtung
zum beispiel und ich glaube das wäre
dann schon auch sehr schätzen wenn er
einfach ein schönes ambiente dort
also jetzt haben wir ein bisschen mehr
über news erfahren wir wissen your
sleeping farbe ist rot ich glaube ich
wird da er auf einen dunkelrot gehen er
interessiert sich sehr für musik und
holz er ist ein großer kaffeeliebhaber
und er mag auch ganz gerne gin und wein
und verbringt seinen urlaub gern in
seinem wahn und eine große leidenschaft
teilen wir und zwar das etikettieren und
katzen geld muffin mama kann dein
auftritt
[Musik]
ok dann geht's los planen wir mal was
kirche los hat eine eher ländliche küche
also vom raum herr sie ist nicht klein
wenn man sie optimal plant und ich
glaube wir bekommen dann auch relativ
guten stauraum hin die küche ist
länglich mit zugang zum flur oder vom
flur und hinten raus hatte ein fenster
oder balkontüren auf der einen seite
hatte auch ein fenster das heißt sie ist
auch ganz gut lichtdurchflutet und ich
muss schauen dass ich die küche mit dem
wohnzimmer so ein bisschen verbinde da
es zwischen drink ein esszimmer gibt das
heißt die küche schließt direkt ins
wohnzimmer an und sollte dementsprechend
auch so ein bisschen in den raum
integriert werden okay die gegebenheiten
sind wasseranschlüsse sind schon
vorhanden die würde ich jetzt da auch
gar nicht versetzen das wäre alles viel
zu viel aufwand und der dunstabzug nach
außen ist auch schon vorhanden das heißt
das greife ich jetzt auf und werde jetzt
hier meine ideen einfach mal mit
reinbringen zuerst werde ich mir jetzt
auch überlegen welche geräte ich
führerschein bauen möchte und geht
deswegen einfach hier auf der seite von
bosch mal durch welche geräte ich haben
will auf jeden fall soll es im backofen
werden und kombi gerät mit dampfgarer
zum beispiel weil ich eben weiß dass
just sich eben auch mal gerne gesund
ernährt und so kann er auch mal auf
einmal ein schönes menü zaubern mit dem
dampf backofen er brauche auf jeden fall
ein kühlschrank mit gefrierfach so dass
er da immer alles griffbereit hat ein
großes kochfeld er kocht nämlich auch
wirklich sehr gerne einen dunstabzug der
am besten an der wand montiert wird da
ich dort eben den dunstabzug bzw die
abluft nach außen habe und eine
spülmaschine und da muss ich mal schauen
vom platz her ob das alles hinten
aufgeht denn hinten an der zeile habe
ich ein bisschen wenig platz muss ich
sagen ich muss wahrscheinlich mit einem
schrank arbeiten und wenn da ein großes
waschbecken hinkommen soll dann glaube
ich wird der platz zu eng für eine große
spülmaschine aber da kann man ja zur not
auch einfach auf eine kleine
spülmaschine zurückgreifen und wer weiß
vielleicht ist sogar viel besser
bei den bosch geräten lasse ich mich
jetzt mal kurz beraten da gibt es eine
online beratung
von einem geschäft das
paket aus mich kurz vor mir selber
beraten ich kenne die rätsel ich so viel
war raus aber ich gucke mir noch kurz
fertig und ich finde die beratungsfirma
sehr gut geworden
[Musik]
das thema wasser platz ist ja auch ganz
wichtig und ich denke bevor ihr auch zum
küchenstudio geht solltet ihr euch auf
jeden fall mal darüber informieren was
ihr vielleicht auch haben wollt wie es
aussehen soll was wir funktionen hier
haben möchtet wobei euch ein großes
küchenstudio natürlich auch beraten wird
aber wenn ihr schon mal so eine kleine
vorahnung habt was ihr haben möchtet wie
zum beispiel dunkle spülbecken sind
granit oberfläche keramik welches
material oder doch lieber edelstahl dann
denke ich seid ihr da im küchenstudio
einfach auch besser aufgehoben und ich
werde jetzt hier einfach mal
durchschauen auf jeden fall eine große
spüle stylish musste aussehen schön
großen wasser platz
alles schön integriert
und ein gutes abfall trennsystem
und es sieht gut aus
dann geht es jetzt ans individualisieren
ein großes zentrales element in jos
küche soll auf jeden fall die kaffeebar
sein und deswegen würde ich die schon so
als eyecatcher direkt an den eingang
setzen praktisch direkt hier am anfang
damit der josch wenn er eben aus dem
flur kommt direkt an der kaffeebar sich
schon mal den ersten kaffee ziehen kann
das soll hier vorne stattfinden und dann
würde ich auch sagen dass wir über dem
kühlschrank so eine art den ball dann
platzieren oder beim kühlschrank eben
dort wurde getränke sein sollen ich muss
mal schauen ob das hat über dem
kühlschrank oder daneben sein wird was
ich hier auch habe ist eine kleine
küchen insel vor dran arbeiten kann und
ich glaube weil die jungs nicht so der
mensch ist der wahrscheinlich ein
esstisch decken wird ist es glaube ich
ganz gut wenn ich an diese küchen insel
und der erarbeiten kann einfach so eine
art ba anschließe und
die bar dann als esstisch dient und noch
als erweiterter arbeitsplatz
als er sich mal wirklich richtig
austoben will in der küche dann hat er
dort noch mal eine schöne fläche zum
arbeiten ich würde auch sagen dass er
eine muslima bekommt auf jeden fall ich
kann mal schauen ob ich die richtung
café bar
anschließen oder ob es dort zu eng wird
und woanders platz hat aber auf jeden
fall das was ich dort morgens auch immer
sein porridge machen kann oder sein
müsli sollen wir es hier bei der arbeit
eben auch immer machen
ich werde mal schauen für welche freunde
ich mich da entscheiden werde aber auf
jeden fall ist licht ganz wichtig holz
ist ganz wichtig es soll eine schöne
warme atmosphäre sein und trotzdem recht
stylisch sein und vielleicht so eine art
bar feeling sogar in der küche dass man
reinkommt und denkt okay jetzt befinde
ich mich hier in der bar und fühle mich
wohl und bin bei mir zu hause ja ich
glaube ich packe jetzt einfach mal meine
ersten ideen zusammen habe hierauf
interest noch fleißig ideen geschaut und
schauen wir noch ein paar fronten an und
dann treibe ich mich gleich mit jörg in
werl und wird dort die küchen
ausstellung anschauen
nehmt euch auf jeden fall ganz viel zeit
für die planung nehmen den plan auch
gerne mal mit nach hause schaut ihn
nochmal durch passt der stauraum habt
ihr vielleicht zu viele dinge die ihr
verstauen ist oder passen die schubladen
wie ihr sie beim küchen berater geplant
hat und dann ist es auch immer ganz
wichtig sich einen termin beim
küchenplaner zu machen damit die eben
auch zeit haben um euch zu beraten
wir sind jetzt hier in nordrhein
westfalen und hier ist der hauptsitz der
firma mobilia mobiliar stellt jeden tag
3750 küchen her und hat insgesamt 4200
mitarbeiter also schon ziemlich
beeindruckend und ihr müsst euch so
vorstellen da hinten im werk kommen das
holz an wird verarbeitet und vorne kommt
die fertige küche raus also wirklich
made in germany made in werl und dann
wird es einfach ausgeliefert in die
ganze welt
[Musik]
jetzt führt mich jörg durch die nobilia
küchenausstellung wir schauen uns
gemeinsam verschiedene küchen an und
dann werden wir die ersten 3d entwürfe
für jungs küche planen
der näheren
ist die küche sortiert ist sein leben
sortiert ich frage sie wieder
[Musik]
ein bisschen mut zur farbe rostrot hast
es erfasst über uns ich glaub es geht
schon in seine richtung weilrod ist so
eines seiner lieblings farben mag ja
ganz gerne ich glaube die ganze küche
vielleicht nicht das sieht man sich
vielleicht auch schnell satt wobei das
rostrot eigentlich schon eine schöne
farbe ist also jetzt ich weiss mal hat
er eine zeitlang knallrot aber ich
glaube dass da sieht man sich sofort
aber so rostrot in kombi mit dunkel oder
hell wird schon in seine richtung gehen
glaube ich wie viel zu dieses detail mit
der glas das ist finde ich auch da hamma
also das vielleicht an der theke sogar
und dann kann jetzt deco hat er
vielleicht nicht aber wenn er das in
gusseisen bretter zum beispiel mit rein
stellt den er dann auch oft zum kochen
benötigt und damit dem licht das finde
ich schon schick ja ein schönes detail
ans planen würde ich sagen okay ich
sonst sehe ich noch mehr und dann
entscheiden
[Musik]
also haben wir hier mal eine moderne
küche geplant die auch gut platz
technisch reinpasst aber wollen sie doch
noch ein bisschen verändern weil ich
glaube jetzt ist sie so auch noch zu
standard ich glaube auch dass jetzt
nicht unbedingt der typ ist er so am
esstisch sitzt sondern vielleicht
gesundheit morath sondern vielleicht
weil wir es wirklich mit seiner theke
die dann so extra hoch dass er gar keine
normalen stadt sowie hier sondern
wirklich nur barocker oder dran stehen
ja okay dann muss ich mal überlegen wie
wir das vielleicht technisch hinkriegen
ist nicht so ganz einfach mit so einer
hohen theke vor allem mit den höhen aber
ja ich gucke mir auch deutlich was
machbar ist oh
ja das ist wohl eher mit der theke und
und dem klar sieht für dich warm und
einladend aus auch mit den drei faktoren
ja es ist geschafft die küche ist
geplant das war wirklich ganz ganz viel
arbeit etliche stunden planung oft haben
wir die planung auch wieder umgeworfen
aber die planung steht jetzt und ich
glaube es wird die perfekte küche für j
die küche wird angeliefert die montage
geht los und da nimmt durch murat mit
und zeigt euch mal den aufbau
[Musik]
dass
mario claudio di padova ist die monteure
die schauen sie jetzt das ganze richtig
an ob der york das richtig gemessen habe
wie sieht's aus wie immer voll ehrlich
uns wenn ihr so eine küche geplante
kommt und er geht im raum denen nur
dieser vor drin war ich gehe da immer
mal was man denkt oh gott das war nicht
richtig eingezeichnet oder conti mal was
fordern ganz ehrlich das wie so ein
überraschungsei jeden morgen motto wir
machen wir das jetzt aber kriegs
immerhin
passt auch lustig macht die drecksarbeit
ich schleppe das ganze zeug hier ein und
ihr seid die ingenieure und sagt einfach
nicht machen so einblicke auspacken ok
alles klar
[Musik]
so dass ich jetzt soll die nischen
rückwand und da tue jetzt karten im
claudio zeigen wie das gemacht wird
andersrum
und zwar brauche ich jetzt einmal kurz
durch
nimmst du wieder raus genau und dann
kommen nämlich die bohr krone rein oder
bei euch da
hatten die baumkrone rein weil da kommt
nachher die steckdose rein hab ich recht
mario genau einfach claudia klar lacht
tun
so haben sie sei froh dass du mit mir
nicht zusammenarbeiten mich ohne sitzt
du also brauchen wir erst mit denen auch
noch mal voll okay und dann machen wir
die box und drauf und dann kannst du
unter branchen einfach richtig
[Musik]
während die männer jetzt noch aufbauen
kümmere ich mich schon mal um die
einrichtung heute wird gemalt heute bei
uns sonntag und wir uns gedacht ich
möchte ein bild fürs küche malen und
samira und enger machen heute mit wird
sagen wir legen direkt los oder ich mal
einfach was schönes was passt ich habe
mich so ein bisschen orientiert oder
inspirieren lassen von dem bild was wir
damals mal bei nobilia xing haben ich
hab das abfotografiert und bioshock sagt
mensch das gefällt mir gut ich glaube so
was ähnliches mahlich los gehts mädels
[Musik]
für den jungs haben wir so eine front
ausgesuchten heißt bei nobilia easy
touch easy touch ist ich mache mal ganz
kurz das macht natürlich erst eine küche
fertig ist aber kommen
mini-konzert wir das mal kurz an also
keine handabdrücke wirklich nicht echt
cool muss ehrlich sagen kannst du machen
was du bist dir gar nichts nicht mal ein
forensiker würde hier noch
fingerabdrücke finden ja
seine terrasse vorm haus und haltet euch
fest es ist wirklich so dass eine kiwi
bäume
und jetzt kommt meine frau
ja ich schon ich arbeite jetzt gucke ich
mir mal die küche an wie es momentan
aussieht ich habe ein bisschen proviant
dabei kuchen für das montage
[Musik]
also die wahl sei okay und hier die
cerealien und das alles ja ich weiß dass
ich habe die kirche geplant
ja
dieses diese diesen grillen ton machen
kontakt sehr genau
[Musik]
viele werden
der apfel fällt nicht weit vom stamm
also hier ist noch ein bisschen was zu
tun die zeit wird knapp ich würde sagen
ich geh jetzt mal besorgungen machen
lasst den mann hier alleine weiter
schaffen und dann wird die küche
aufgepumpt
mach nix kaputt okay
gespielt
[Musik]
ja jetzt ist die küche fertig montiert
und ich muss sagen die sieht richtig
richtig gut aus bevor ich die küche
jetzt einrichte und euch zeigen muss ich
sie natürlich erst mal putzen am besten
nehme dir dafür wirklich auf baumwoll
tücher und keine mikrofasertücher der
microfaser sind einfach viel zu hart und
würden hier die oberflächen einfach
verkratzen also da generell einfach
drauf achten die glasoberflächen mit
einem glasreiniger reinigen und
ansonsten lege ich jetzt direkt los ich
würde sagen max wie kamera weg wir
putzen gleich zusammen oder herr murat
ural
komm hilf putzen dann sind wir schneller
vettel
mach du
ich putz nass und trocken okay
[Musik]
man muss schon nicht da oben gekürzt da
ist noch
schlechter
vorm haus maria skiba und wir hatten wie
soll es einen blinden passagier in einer
der keine miete gezahlt und zwar nach
oben ziehe die taube und brütet da oben
und machen nichts kann also
ich glaube dass ich nicht mit dem blau
kopfhaube
ja und zwar das sieht man weil sie in
bangkok wird
[Musik]
es sieht nicht danach aus aber das hier
wird möglich die schöne westerkappeln
[Musik]
vorratsdosen am besten wenn was
aufbewahrt wird kommt er meist in den
kühlschrank und deswegen schaue ich mal
vielleicht nutzen würde unten den platz
für vorratsdosen
[Musik]
sie habe ich noch eine kleine
überraschung versteckt denn es gibt ja
auch dinge wie zum beispiel yorks
heißluft fritteuse schwer ist groß nicht
so schön zum hinstellen und diese geräte
sonstige geräte alles was man vielleicht
auch gar nicht so oft braucht werden wir
drunter verpacken denn hier habe ich
einen ex schrank dass wir praktisch euch
hinten dieses tote etwas man oft hat
eben auch nutzt dabei den kesseböhmer
dämmung eingebaut hat man dann kann man
das hier so rausholen und wieder weg
stellen oder auch mal große töpfe die
jetzt nicht in eine normale schublade
passen und dann hatte das da hinten drin
und wirklich den platz in der küche
optimal genutzt
dann geht's los dann hören wir jetzt
alle kisten und räumen ein denn ich
zeige euch jetzt was praktisch so die
grundausstattung in der küche ist er hat
ja im prinzip nicht viel bzw der philipp
bringt mir alles vorbei was im alten
haushalt drin ist und alles andere habe
ich mitgebracht und richtige jetzt die
küche ein
ich habe jetzt auch noch barhocker
besorgt für die küche denn man will ja
auch nicht die zeit beim essen stehen
sondern sich vielleicht auch noch an den
barock ersetzen soll trainiert mit
durchschnittlich großes model muras
zeigt euch jetzt wenn man daran sicher
ist ganz schon ein bisschen zu tief weil
ich bin jetzt zum beispiel schneiden
würde müsste ich so hoch und dann so
schneiden es ist total bescheuert und
sehr genossen geschnitten jetzt mal ja
schon mal im schlüssel gemacht und bin
im garten dann wäre es den blöde sache
ja und es heißt ihr bauten partei ist
hier doch wir bauen prozessen im knie
zusammen er hat zwar zwei linke hände
aber ich denke ist immer favorit
[Musik]
sollte jetzt die unterkonstruktion und
ich richtig leicht karl eintrag oder
soll ich dir helfen ja
und jetzt habe ich eine usb platte und
die usb platte schrauben wir auch drauf
also wir tun sie erstmal das
zurechtschneiden dann tut man sich drauf
schrauben und haben eine sehr starke
konstruktion und auf diese usb platte
mit nach hin natürlich die eichen platte
darauf geschaut was ist das türkische
oder deutscher eiche
ja genau so ich gebe dir gleich
[Musik]
genau werden auch genau wie jetzt
richtig ausgelöst haben castro dass wir
ohne zwang kassen
perfekt
[Musik]
wenn ich bin ich wenig genießt daraufhin
habe ich den anschluss verlieren ja ich
könnte jetzt einfach so wegwischen er
macht man ja
darüber nach wie vor
gehen einkaufen
so kurzen armen und nahrungsmittel ich
habe die lücke milch butter und eier
salz pfeffer und paprika
zwiebel es
gut hier habe ich jetzt mal so
grundausstattung kochen und vorbereiten
also was finde ich persönlich in der
küche nicht fehlen darf ich sehe gerade
philipp kommt gerade machen kurz die tür
auf dann zeige ich euch gleich weiter
philipp kommt rein
hallo ich
habe euch noch was mit
fast einem jahrzehnt noch bei münster
halten und hat noch sein lieblings
getöse von der eltern mitgebracht und
die kann ja noch paar sachen von ihm ich
habe sogar also was heute schon immer
noch schnell
richtig ist wenn ja ist ein paar
spezialitäten von daheim mitgebracht
du sollst du eigentlich was helfen
wollen du wenn du magst kannst du gerne
die sachen vom yc vielleicht kannst du
dir in bar werden folgen dann mache ich
hier so lange geschirr und besteck
freunde sind da wenn man sie darum
die passende note 1 fecher dass wir so
ist das freute sich über seinen
primitiven
an alles gedacht
[Musik]
danke dir den rest mache ich dann mein
gott dann noch viel sport
die haben wir jetzt wieder so das thema
kurze laufwege der goz beschwert sich
bei uns in der küche immer dass du so
weit laufen muss wenn er zum beispiel
das besteck anrichtet aber gut unsere
küche ist auch arbeitsplatz und studio
und groß aber deswegen habe ich gedacht
der mir zuliebe besteck kommt direkt
hier rein da muss man nicht mal einen
schritt weg machen und hat sofort alles
versäumt lediglich beim geschirr muss
ich sagen dass teile ich jetzt ein
bisschen auf denn ich habe mir gedacht
hier kommt ja die müsli dahin also werde
ich die müsli schüsseln dahin rein
sortieren ist auch sehr dekorativ muss
ich sagen und das andere geschirr kommt
er hier richtung theke weil hier wird ja
auch gegessen
[Musik]
gutes immer wenn er über oder unter dem
backofen eine schublade habt oder den
schrank wo ihr einfach backbleche und
back zubehör verstorben können denn die
meisten machen dass er im backofen
arbeitsstelle ich vorerst eine recht
kleine küche habt ihr vielleicht die
ganzen backbleche drin und müsste dann
jedesmal vorder benutzung erstmal
rausholen und irgendwo abstellen und ich
finde es gut wenn man im backofen
entweder nur so lochblech hat oder im
backofen rust dann kann man nämlich auch
von unterwegs aus also zumindest bei mir
so bei mir schutz auch weil der home
connect fähige backöfen sind kann von
unterwegs aus praktisch die backöfen
schon anschalten mal weiß ganz genau was
steht nichts drin was verbrennen kann
und alle zubehörteile sind hier schön
sortiert runter oder eben darüber
[Musik]
hier bin ich jetzt in der vorbereitungs
zone das heißt salat
zubereiten gemüse schnippeln zutaten
vermischen und ich habe mir überlegt
kann der ja schon küchenmaschine
gebrauchen eigentlich ja die kann
natürlich jeder gebrauchen aber dann
habe ich weitere belegt und mir gedacht
der ist ja auch oft unterwegs mit seinem
camper und deswegen habe ich ihn jetzt
praktisch tools hier mit rein dich jetzt
die reinräume werte die er hier in der
küche nutzen kann und aber dann auch mit
in den camper nehmen kann weil alles
ohne strom funktioniert das heißt hier
zum beispiel die trommel reife damit
kann man nur zu zerkleinern gemüsehobel
obst käse wurst und alles mögliche
genauso der kleine speed ring der als
mixa dient und eben diese kleinen mixa
hat und ist es eben gut er kann es hier
verwenden und eben auch ohne strom
unterwegs oder draußen auf der terrasse
und was ich hier auch habe also gerade
hier der transformer zum beispiel den
kann er hier mit dem fuß fest machen zb
ein ceranfeld oder auf glatten
oberflächen oder wenn er hier an der
theke arbeiten will kann man hier das
ganze auch damit festmachen und
praktisch hier an der küchentheke
festmachen und so kann er auch wenn er
mal zu zweit zu dritt zu viert kocht
kann einer dastehen einer hier einer da
und man kann das ganze verteilen ohne
dass sich jeder im weg steht
[Musik]
gut das beste ist auch ganz praktisch
ich kann nämlich diese abstände diese
abteilungen einfach individuell
einstellen hier zum beispiel ein
bisschen schmaler für die hobel und da
auch direkt zubehör dazu dann weiß er
immer ganz genau wo er alles findet und
hier ein bisschen breiter da kann zum
beispiel der speed ring
rhein-wied ring zubehör
und noch berger presse
und dann hat alles seinen platz
[Musik]
er ist schon fast alles eingeräumt und
wir sind hier bei pimp my kitchen
deswegen welches müsli theke müsli bahn
noch gepimpt ich habe mir gedacht so
richtig wie im hotel einfach indem es
lieber aufzubauen mit dem ganzen
geschirr mit den vorräten mit müsli
haferflocken leinsamen cornflakes war es
ist auch alles gibt habe hier auch schon
tolle lampe ausgesucht denn das ganze
wird ja wirklich heute bis morgen noch
fertiggestellt sodass die küche komplett
einsatzbereit ist und der auch schon
überrascht werden kann
[Musik]
hat sich will jetzt nicht sagen es wäre
aber eine lieblingsbeschäftigung aber
doch
es ist meine lieblingsbeschäftigung
etikettieren unterbrechen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt geht's an die gewürz schublade und
ich habe mir gedacht ich nehme jetzt
hier einfach kleine irgendwann schott
clay sollte geht natürlich auch in groß
als mutig leser und vor allem facharzt
leser muss man eben nicht einfach
wegschmeißen man kann sie immer wieder
verwerten gut wie gesagt ich könnte
ihnen gläsern drin lassen aber
stylischer wird wenn ich es um fülle vor
allem weil ich in der schublade machen
möchte und die da gar nicht reinpassen
und ja ich will jetzt hier rein
[Musik]
man ist erst ein richtiger hardcore wenn
man kreuzkümmel daheim
ja eine alte
38 noch dran ja wenn ihr jetzt noch dran
seid dann könnt ihr auch was gewinnen
nämlich einen gutschein in höhe von 1000
euro für eure küchenausstattung bei
www.smava.de und alles was ihr dafür tun
müsst ist folgende kommentar zu
hinterlassen
schreibt mir doch gerne einmal unter
dieses video worauf ihr bei euch in der
küche achtet seid ihr eher fan von farbe
oder seid ihr eher team neutral aber
schreibt mir gerne auch warum ihr auf
farbe zurückgreifen würden oder warum
ihr euch keine neutralen küche
entscheiden würde gleich gehts weiter
nach der werbung
[Musik]
brücken
jetzt geht's an die kaffeebar die kommt
hier hin momentan sieht es noch nicht
nach einer kaffeebar aus aber ich habe
für jascha siebträgermaschine bestellt
denn er hat ja zu hause bei seinen
eltern auch eine und hat die man benutzt
hat dann auch immer fotos geschickt von
seinen wahnsinnigen kunstwerken die
jetzt natürlich mit der zeit wird noch
besser werden da er jetzt seine eigene
sie träger maschine bekommt und dann
kann er richtig latte art machen die
packe ich jetzt aus und dann schaue ich
wie ich seine kaffee ecke noch kippen
kann max kann schon mal kurz helfen die
ist glaube ich schwer
ja
[Musik]
für den schönen akzent an der kaffeebar
mund hier ich jetzt noch ein schönes
regal aus massivem eichenholz damit die
kaffeebar so ein bisschen einen warmen
touch bekommt eine hochwertige
siebträgermaschine hat natürlich auch
gutes zu gehört zum einen habe ich hier
eine kaffeemühle mit einer abklopft
schublade eigentlich wollten wir eine
art club schublade hier unten einbauen
aber der josch lebte hier alleine und
diese café müller hat praktisch hier die
abklopft schublade da passt es auch ganz
gut kann er direkt an den kaffee auch
später entsorgen und damit das ganze
hier nicht einfach so rum fährt oder er
ist in die schublade irgendwie verräumen
muss habe ich mir gedacht richtig dass
hier schön an und dann hat er eben schön
alles verstaut aber doch sehr dekorativ
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt eine deko für die
kaffeebar dafür nimmt ihr einfach ein
holzstück das ist einfach ein rest wenig
zugeschnitten hat tafel lack und eine
rolle und jetzt könnte ich hier das
holzstückchen mit dem tafel lack schön
bemalen
[Musik]
smolka langweilig
da
[Musik]
damit die kirche direkt beiwohnen kann
gibt es auch grundnahrungsmittel für den
kühlschrank da kann er direkt nach dem
einzug nach dem bezug der küche sofort
mit kochen und backen loslegen
dann habe ich ja schon kalt gemüse habe
ich teilweise eingeräumt aber ich zeige
euch auch wie man lebensmittel richtig
versäumt ich habe da auch mal ein video
darüber gemacht und zwar ist so obst und
gemüse kommen unten rein dann fleisch
und milchprodukte und weiter oben die
dinge die lebensmittel die eben weniger
geld brauchen
seit unserem türkei ausflügen is yours
als hobby türke natürlich bekennender
kaymak fällt deswegen gibt's gleich
trotzdem keiner
[Musik]
jetzt geht's los musik technik und zwar
hat mir sagt dass er eigentlich rund um
die uhr immer musik hört im büro
deswegen habe ich hier die anlage
besorgt habe hier noch einen verstärker
ich hatte auch vorher mit joschka schon
an gespräch und hat praktisch dafür
gesorgt dass so im ganzen haus alles
verbunden ist die verstärker gibt es
dann auch er kann praktisch sein handy
oder sein tablet zum beispiel auch mit
dem haus verbinden und sozusagen überall
musik hören wo er ist überall die
verstärker einbauen und dann spotify
oder alles mögliche streamen deswegen
verstecke ich jetzt hier den verstärker
einfach da oben über den hängeschränken
da habe ich auch schon steckdosen
versteckt und die anlage kommt dann hier
direkt über die küche und ich glaube
dass quilling so ganz gut
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch eine tablet hand
herum und hat von philipp j tablett
bekommen so kann er nämlich auch während
dem kochen oder während des essens
einfach was anschauen ein youtube video
von mir zum beispiel oder auch die app
benutzen die ich darauf installiert htc
app drauf und die home connect app und
habe jetzt auch schon alle busch geräte
mit der app verbunden so kanadier geräte
nämlich steuern und hat eben alles schön
griffbereit und vor allem eben auch sein
tablet da wo es braucht und er kann es
dann hier auch eine richtig coole
halterung das kann auch so quer leben
und wirklich noch schönes anschauen und
eben auch verstauen
dann gibt's noch vasen für jungs küche
und vasen muss man nicht immer kaufen
man kann war es noch ganz toll
selbermachen aus alten flaschen ihr
könnt entweder smoothie flaschen nehmen
weinflaschen egal welche flasche auch da
habt glasflaschen nicht wegschmeißen
sondern wirklich absteigen und ich habe
jetzt hier einfach einen leeren karton
und wenn ihr die hier rein stellt habt
ihr wieso eine kleine lackierkabine und
drumherum wird einfach nichts schmutzig
[Musik]
bei dieser flasche hier nämlich ein
bisschen knapp bank und krebs außen
herum die möchte ich nämlich nicht
komplett wir malen sondern wirklich nur
den unteren teil oder auch nur so ein
streifen und der rest bleibt dann schön
durchsichtig und transparent da kam
nämlich noch schöner lichterkette
reinmachen
[Musik]
ich habe hier noch so karg untersetzer
also glas untersetzer
gekauft und die werde ich jetzt noch
individualisieren dafür nehmen dir
einfach ein bisschen klebeband farbe und
dann könnt ihr die streifen durchs leben
auch ein schönes muster draufkleben und
einfach ein bisschen farbe ins spiel
bringen
[Musik]
jetzt geht's an mein lieblingsthema
nämlich dekorieren
ich bin so ein esstisch oder in der
küchentheke sollte auch ein bisschen
dekoriert sein aber ganz praktisch
dekoriert sein nämlich mit dingen die
man dann auch braucht zum beispiel salz
und pfefferstreuer vielleicht ein
olivenöl oder irgendwas noch dazu von
mir aus auch gläser die untersetzer
packe ich noch hier mit drauf aber eben
auch für die schöne stimmung ein
bisschen kerzen und vasen die ich schon
vorbereitet habe peter weise kann man
jetzt überlegen ob man hier oben
praktisch eine dünne kerze rein steckt
dann kann es auch ein kerzenständer sein
oder man nimmt zum kleine led lampe
kleine led leuchten und steckte ich hier
rein denn schaut mal
ein schönes licht nur schöne deko
[Musik]
es ist verbracht hier ist sie nun los
fertig gepimpte kirche
[Musik]
ich stelle euch jetzt mal die highlights
in jsc acron die theke ist das erste was
man sieht wenn man josch küche betritt
und ich habe jetzt hier nicht nur diese
angenehme arbeit und stehhöhe sondern
ich habe hier auch einen schrank und
zwar wie hier in kesseböhmer tandem mit
reingepackt habt ihr zufolge laden mit
dingen die der jungs zu fürs frühstücken
braucht oder eben auch snacks getränke
und eben alles was er hier für den
hintergrund für die kaffeemaschine
verwendet hier habe ich einfach den
vorteil ein tandem dass ich ein drittel
des schrank inhalt in der tür habe und
zwei drittel im schrank und beim öffnen
der schranktür kommt mir praktisch der
ganze inhalt entgegen ich muss nicht da
hinten irgendwo in einem schrank holen
sondern habe alles griffbereit alles
schön ordentlich und ich weiß auf einen
blick ganz genau was mich jemand schrank
habe und was vielleicht eben auch noch
fehlt je weiter hinten ist dann direkt
auch die müsli ba an dieser küchen insel
die küchen insel ist praktisch zum
arbeiten für jeden tag gedacht die an
der küchen insel habe ich auch von
mobiliar praktisch diese aufladestation
fürs handy das heißt hier kann er auch
beim arbeiten das handy ablegen so dass
sich dieses ganz induktiv auflädt
steckdosen sind hier in der leiste mit
dabei die auch schön versteckt sind dann
habe ich im arbeitsbereich noch hier den
kessel mathis tänzer da habe ich im
prinzip einfach alles wie so ein kleiner
ableger schrank so im junior apotheker
schrank habe alles griffbereit vor allem
bewege ich mich hier wirklich im zentrum
der küche hab da dem korb bereich hier
den spielbereich und hier einfach den
arbeitsbereich und kann von überall aus
hier hin zu greifen hier links habe ich
an der theke dann praktisch nur mit
offenen holzregalen gearbeitet dass er
wirklich hier auch müslischalen hat die
ihr je weiter oben eben auch verwenden
kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein weiteres highlight in der küche ist
der wasser platz und 24 de blanco unit
und das ist die perfekte einheit aus
spüle armatur und 0 organisationssystem
zählt hierbei erscheint ring card
eingebaut von blanco und zwar habe ich
hier rechts einen ganz normalen
wasserhahn praktisch mit kalt warm
wasser zum spülen
hier links habe ich die möglichkeit
kaltes mehrfach gefiltertes wasser zu
ziehen oder eben kochend heißes wasser
auf knopfdruck das heißt jeden sekunden
schneller kochend heißes wasser naja ich
brauche keine teekanne er braucht keinen
wasserkocher und das habe ich jetzt hier
links praktisch und habe trotzdem den
vorteil dass ich einfach nur wirklich
wenige sekunden warten muss kann das
heiße wasser ziehen und ein paar
sekunden später kann ich wieder ganz
normales kaltes gefiltertes trinkwasser
rauslassen was ich auch ganz schön finde
ich habe hier dieses click & touch das
heißt ich kann an dem rädchen drehen und
kann sogar die auslauf menge bestimmen
zum beispiel 200 milliliter kaltes
wasser oder drei liter kochend heißes
wasser ich habe einfach keine
wasserverschwendung keine ressourcen
verschwendung weil ich einfach ganz
genau weiß wie viel wasser ich haben
möchte hier in der mitte ich habe
praktisch drei spielbälle zum einen hier
das große spülbecken hier ein kleines
becken und noch das auslauf becken und
ich habe hier einfach noch eine
pauschale die ich hier rein zu kommen
und hier kann er weil er auch alleine
hier lebt muss ich dazu sagen hier kann
er den biomüll verstauen und dann
draußen einfach im garten entsorgen er
hat nämlich gesagt er wird gar keine
biomülltonne bestellen sondern wird
einfach alles im garten entsorgen wo er
dann alles schön kompostieren kann und
wenn er diese pauschale hier nicht
verwendet keiner sitzung beispiel auch
hier unten in das mülltrennen system mit
reinstellen und
hat dann eben auch alles schön verstaut
wenn man vor dem spülbecken steht habe
ich hier rechts zum beispiel die
geschirrspülmaschine und das ist eine
kleine geschirrspülmaschine von bosch
weil der ja eben hier alleine lebt und
eine große kriegt da eigentlich gar
nicht gefüllt und die kleine kann dann
wirklich anschalten ist platzsparend und
es passt eben auch alles rein was er
hier benutzt jetzt runter sozusagen auch
alles was er zu spielen benutzt
verstauen wie zum beispiel die ganzen
vorräte spül pulver geschirrspülmittel
spülmittel und so weiter ein und einmal
habe ich leer gelassen da kann er zb
sein glas verstauen und daneben
wegfahren zum glascontainer hier ist
dann sozusagen der mülleimer und da kann
er wenn er die hände voll hat einfach
mit dem fuß dagegen da gibt es von
mobiliar das ganz tolle system und so
fährt dann wohl einmal ganz vorne raus
und er kann hier restmüll und wertstoff
ganz gut entsorgen und was ich hier auch
noch habe weil ich weiß dass das zum
beispiel auch tüten die er vom
lieferdienst bekommt wie zum beispiel
vom döner man da bekommen wir immer
diese plastiktüten die wir eigentlich
nicht wollen aber der your shape sie
dann auf und weil diese kleinen tüten
eben oftmals nicht in diese großen
müllbehälter passen gibt noch so select
clips die habe ich ihnen schon mal rein
geklappt da kann nämlich auch kleine
typen die sonst nicht in den mülleimer
passen einfach reinklicken und kann so
eben die mülltüten noch verwerten ohne
sinnlos wegzuschmeißen
ich habe jetzt diese eckhof schränke
links habe ich jetzt mal alle gläser
aufbewahrt so dass er wirklich hier die
gläser nehmen kann sich am wasserhahn an
wasser bedienen kann oder eben die
gläser auch für die gene war zum
beispiel nutzen kann und hier rechts
habe ich seine back vorräte verstaut und
weil man oftmals oben gar nicht so gut
ankommt wo der junge ist groß aber
trotzdem schlechter der partnerin die
etwas kleiner ist oder mama papa komm
vorbei freunde die eben nicht so groß
sind habe ich hier den ein hof eingebaut
da kann er nämlich die vorräte einfach
schön nach unten ziehen manche habe ich
jetzt schon um gefüllt so dass er
einfach schon vorratsdosen hat hier eben
immer wieder auffüllen kann und hier in
der mitte habe ich aber noch platz für
eben verschlossene vorräte weil ich
jetzt nicht so der große kuchenbecker
ist aber zumeist mit pancakes ganz gerne
mal macht oder eben auch noch so was
kleines packt und dann hat er hier
einfach so die wichtigsten backzutaten
dir dann immer individuell nachkaufen
und aufhören kann und hier unten habe
ich an der küchentheke sozusagen das
mosaik system das es ein klick system
was er auch wenn es ihm zum beispiel
jetzt gar nicht gefallen würde selbst
noch austauschen kann man kann hier
diese einzelelemente nämlich wegnehmen
und ganz individuell wieder woanders hin
hängen und ich habe zehn mal eben diesen
ein für die olivenöle oder auch hier den
einsatz wo er auch was drauf schreiben
kann wie zum beispiel eine einkaufsliste
oder eben das ganze als regal benutzen
kann
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt in der kurzone und habe
ein großes den aktionsfeldern richtig
schönes kochfeld wo er wirklich auch
mehrere töpfe und pfannen und einfach
auf einmal benutzen kann und ich hatte
früher bei meiner mutter in der küche
immer das problem eines ungefähr so groß
und sie hatte so einen dunstabzug der
bis hierhin und ich hab mir immer den
kopf angeschlagen und deswegen bin ich
auch ganz froh dass es hier einfach
warnt essen gibt die wirklich schön
flach sind und trotzdem sehr
leistungsstark und gerade beim yaris
bietet sich es hat auch an weil das sehr
groß ist hier drunter habe ich dann
praktisch die schubladen und hier habe
ich jetzt das ganze koch besteck
gelagert was er hier verwendet und auch
die gewürze schön abgefüllt so dass er
alles griffbereit hat in der zweiten
schublade dann noch pfannen und töpfe
und ich habe jetzt hier auch überlegt
wie viel kommt beim josch in die küche
erlebt momentan zwar allein aber er hat
ja auch viele freunde und gäste die ihn
immer wieder besuchen und deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht er kocht ganz gerne in
gusseisen das weiß ich und deswegen habe
ich ihn jetzt zwei kreisen töpfe
reingestellt einmal den morath einmal
die ella weil er darin einfach schön
kochen kann und damit eben auch mal was
anbraten kann oder seiner heißgeliebten
pen fix machen kann diesen flachen
gusseisen tropfens für die flache pfanne
das ist wirklich nämlich universell
einsetzbar das heißt er braucht wirklich
nur diese panne die eckige er schwärmt
von der eckigen fahne dir schon für
seine eltern in der küche hatte und da
weiß ich einfach er bereitet hier alles
zur sowohl des frühstücks ei als auch
keinen keks pfannkuchen und deswegen
brauche auch keine beschichtete pfanne
oder nochmal eine eisen pfanne sondern
hat wirklich einfach ein universalgerät
für alles und hier unten habe ich dann
noch den einsatz von nobilia mit drin
und da kann er einfach seine vorräte
reinpacken die noch verschlossen sind
und dann hat auch alles schön
übersichtlich kann von oben rein schauen
und ich denke auch dass eben diese eine
schublade ausreichend wird und weil der
jungs eben ein großer
weinliebhaber ist habe ich hier einfach
dieses holzelementen geplant da der
seine weinflaschen jetzt drin hat die
auch beim kochen immer griffbereit oder
eben hier am tisch dann habe ich hier
den bug und zwar ist er schön auf
ökonomischer höhe schön erhöht gebaut so
dass es sich einfach nicht nach unten
wirken muss und ich habe hier ein
multifunktionsgerät von bosch das ist
nämlich der backofen der volldampf
besitzt das heißt der jsc an den
backofen als dampfgarer benutzen aber
eben auch nur den dampf stoß benutzen
und es finde ich schon ganz gut weil so
der backofen mich nur ein backofen ist
sondern wirklich so ein
multifunktionsgerät was er eben
individuell einsetzen kann und jetzt
kommen wir zum letzten und
wahrscheinlich für josch wichtigsten
highlight nämlich sorgt kaffeebar hier
ist die café bar mit einer richtig
hochwertigen griff siebträgermaschine
und hier drunter habe ich auch sozusagen
noch diese schubladen und es ist so 80
prozent der briefe werde in der küche
geöffnet also wenn ihr euch jetzt mal
überlegt ihr seid zum briefkasten
gelaufen holt die briefe nach hause wo
öffnet ihr sie es ist wirklich zu 80
prozent der briefe werden bei alle in
der küche geöffnet und dann hat man
immer so eine schublade die vielleicht
ein bisschen unordentlich hier ist die
briefe liegen herum papierkram liegt
herum vielleicht doch der stundenplan
der kinder oder alles mögliche was man
so an papierkram und hat deswegen habe
ich mir überlegt dass ich diese oberste
schublade hier wenn er praktisch direkt
vom eingang hier rein läuft einfach eine
brief und organisations schublade hat
ich habe ich im prinzip sein etikett
gerät verstaut die ganzen
fernbedienungen habe hier noch ein
bisschen schreibkram also stift und
zettel dass es sich eben auch mal was
notieren kann habe aber auch platz für
briefe und wichtiges wasser hier einfach
mal unterbringen kann wenn es nicht
gleich bearbeiten möchte oder kann kann
es hier ablegen und sieht trotzdem
ordentlich aus und es keine rumpel
schublade hier oben wie gesagt die
organisation 1 weiter unten habe ich
dann das geschirr das habt ihr
vielleicht bisher schon vermisst und
habe denkt euch vielleicht wieso stets
nicht da vorne bei den gläsern aber ich
habe mir gedacht gerade bei porzellan
geschirr was eben auch mal schwer ist
und geräumig ist das habe ich jetzt hier
auf der höhe auch ökonomisch eingeräumt
so dass man es wirklich will hier direkt
praktisch hier alle theke stellen kann
und eben wieder zurück und dann hat man
alles schön griffbereit und eben auch
sauber ordentlich das war meine küchen
rundgang und die küche von j und jetzt
werde ich sagen kohlen wir ja schon
überraschen
[Musik]
ich hoffe es gefällt ihr
kind kam herein
ich bin sprachlos
[Musik]
es wird eine barista ecke weil ich ja
weißt du bist so der barista und schickt
mir manchmal schwer faktisch ist uns
willkommen der ganzen linie ja da hat
mir der philipp kohl von also daher ist
das hergebrachte eingerollt ja ein
heißluft fritteuse und die heißt der
fritzlarer mitgebracht was ist die
aufnahme
ganz gut finde es eigentlich möglich
spender visueller machtwechsel darunter
und kam her
kann ich da mal dran drehen ja
genau denn so wird genau einfach runter
ziehen und jetzt die schale durch
und einfach drehen
sehr sehr schön doch
[Musik]
sag ich mal kurz ja
ok
ok russisch ziemlich abgefahren schon
beschriftet natürlich ich habe jetzt
schon die küche geplant um eingerichtet
und ich werde jetzt ganz gerne bittet
seinem versprechen pancakes einlösen und
ein cappuccino
beeinflusst die küche ist der
absolute wahnsinn
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also mission geglückt josch gefällt
seine neue küche ich bin wirklich sehr
froh darüber denn ja gut also ich habe
mich umgehört und ich meine ich kenne
organisch und vieles hat sein beitrag
dazu geleistet deine kollegen haben
weitere airlines auch die kaffeebar also
wir lassen uns jetzt schmecken das macht
den text für uns vielen dank dass sie
nicht dabei hat danke auch an alle
partner die uns hier bei pimp my kitchen
unterstützen und und unter die arme
greifen und ich freue mich schon auf die
nächste folge denn da werden auch ganz
ganz besondere menschen mit einer küche
überrascht
die leuchten ja aber mit
innenraumbeleuchtung
[Musik]
also vor der kamera so habe ich das noch
nicht gemacht ist mein bestes ok ok
keine erfolgsgarantie bitte ich bin ich
bin da ich bin überwältigt von den
ganzen eindrücken und jetzt muss ich
nicht gekommen
das schaffst das wird schon
[Musik]
also das was du hier bist du hast sie
wirklich als lebenslänglich espresso
cappuccino
müsli porridge und natürlich keine
kriegs je maximal lebenslang wie
versprochen er hat es drauf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du setzt dich jetzt dahin
und wenn dann siehst du deine verdienten
feierabend quasi wenn das hier gibt's
dann ist die panne hat die hält die
temperatur dann weiß ich so gar nicht
du hast die zwei abend ich mache jetzt
pancakes
los geht's
[Musik]
diese kirche ist
gefärbt
das gibt es so sehr
ich liebe die ich machen ich liebe dich
[Musik]
muss für eure küchenausstattung bei
www.soulsite.de
alles was ihr dafür tun müsst ich
versuche seriös zu wirken wie in der tv
werbung
[Musik]